I need to make an example of tony blais no
judge is going to take this seriously unless
we do things by the book oh book of the shanty
welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my full she-hook episode 4 video there were
a whole bunch of marvel easter eggs so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i'm
doing videos for all the episodes just like
i do for the other marvel disney plus series
marvel disney plus day is also happening this
weekend there's supposed to be a bunch of big
trailers a bunch of big announcements of course
i'll be doing videos for all that stuff as well
too careful for spoilers for the episode if you
haven't seen it yet we'll start at the beginning
and work our way through shot by shot talking
about easter eggs and wtf moments as we go along
starting with the episode title the episode
was called is this not real magic which is a
reference to wong suing the magician pretending
to be a full-blown sorcerer turns out there was
a student at kamar taj but was just a total dirt
back and they kicked him out after a week and he
stole a sling ring and has been causing trouble
at his magic venue ever since using the most
ghost writer name he could possibly think of the
showrunner actually explained what was going on
with the ghost rider name because he's calling
himself donnie blaze obviously that's meant to
be a reference to johnny blaze the fire dimension
that he keeps sending people to is supposed to be
a reference to marvel's version of held there
a couple different dimensions in the mcu that
you could call hell just in general like they're
called the hell lords and there are a couple of
major characters that you associate with that like
you can make all the mephisto jokes that you want
madison keeps talking about a demon that she made
a contract with like she sold her soul to be sent
back home that's what they basically showed during
the post credit scenes like her signing her soul
away i gave a couple drops of my blood signed a
contract and he sent me back i'm not allowed to
talk about it the goat-looking demon is another
reference to a version of the devil like it's a
form that the devil takes but the name tag on it
that says jake in the end credit scene is depicted
as if it's drawn by the court artist based on what
madison told them so it's like his account of what
madison remembered kind of wrong so the demon's
name probably wasn't jake i couldn't actually
find any demons in marvel comics whose names
start with a j so i just assumed that madison
probably got that part wrong because she kind of
brushes over a lot of what happened like yeah that
was his fire dimension it was a good looking demon
that i sold my soul to it's all fine no big deal
he's just gonna steal my soul and the souls of all
the people that i love if i tell too many people
about this because this is wong we're dealing with
doctor strange mythology from the comics obviously
they've been setting up a lot of more supernatural
stuff just in the mcu in general heading on the
path to introducing characters like ghost rider i
believe the actual dimension that she was sent to
is the same dimension that you see doctor strange
in america chavez traveling through as they go
through the multiverse like in the background it
looks kind of like this and it looks a little bit
like mephisto's dimension in the comics too but
that's basically the references that they're going
for like okay yeah we're going for ghost rider
stuff here the actual opening scene of the episode
starts with a metal cover and the magician donnie
blaze pretending to use magic with a little bit of
real magic thrown in there when he mentions billy
shakes that's a reference to william shakespeare
a rose by any name and the venue that he's working
at is called the mystical castle that's an easter
egg for the real life los angeles area magic
castle but they basically explain he got his hands
on the sling ring when he was briefly a student at
comartaj and they make a bunch of jokes about wong
not forming actual contracts or getting anything
in writing with any of the potential students that
come along through carmartach maybe he's gonna
change that after the events of this episode
wong is chilling out getting ready to watch
sopranos episodes on this giant flat screen tv
turns out he has a lot of modern amenities
they made a couple of jokes about that during
the first doctor strange movie like oh here's the
wi-fi password like they actually have wi-fi even
though it seems super old-timey in last week's
episode they also revealed his linkedin page
he worked at a target in comartage so like even
though it doesn't seem like it kamar taj probably
has a bunch of regular businesses that you would
see in any of the big city madison then explains
how she gets sent back to this 616 mcu universe by
selling her soul to the demon the other thing here
is that this event with madison seems like it's
the straw that broke the camel's back for him like
that's enough mostly because he got his episode of
the sopranos spoiled for him and he blames donnie
blaze for it and he vows revenge then jennifer
walters breaks the fourth wall one of many many
fourth wall breaks in the episode they're like
several of them way more than previous episodes
joking about how everybody is super happy because
wong is back calling it twitter armor like twitter
will be nicer to the episode because of all the
ghost rider and the wong stuff then when they
go to her office and they show you like the super
long to-do list that she has she says she's buying
purple and green highlighters because they're
whole colors she's buying much larger clothes that
will fit her in she-hole form that kind of happens
through the course of the episode too where she
seems like she's going to be spending more time in
she-hulk form just because all the guys that she's
trying to date seem like they're way more into
the thick version of jennifer walters she-hulk
than they are to the regular version like there's
all these things in her life all these different
aspects of her life that are telling her that
she'd be better off in she-hulk form there's
another joke about wasting chopsticks buying more
and buying way more cheetos because she's eating
way more flamin hot cheetos on the regular and she
eats them with chopsticks that's a big call back
to the first episode and it's also an oscar isaac
joke because in real life just like completely
separately before oscar isaac did all the moon
nights stuff there was this funny photo of him
eating flamin hot cheetos with chopsticks but
there are actually a lot of people in real life
that said they do that too then when they scroll
way down the list there's a whole bunch of names
of big comic book creators at marvel in the
form of cases that she's working on so craft
v sewell is david anthony craft who worked on
a bunch of incredible hulk comics for a while
and charles sewell who writes a ton of the star
wars comics that marvel publishes the lee vs
byrne is jim lee in john byrne jim lee famously
worked on a bunch of marvel comics before he
went to dc and did a lot of his own stuff in the
big john byrne easter egg here too is because he
actually wrote the sensational she-hulk comic book
which was the comic where she started breaking the
fourth wall which she does so many times in this
episode and the rest of the series just in general
and all that started years before deadpool started
breaking the fourth wall so maybe someday they'll
meet in the mcu and they'll have some jokes
about that in real life tatiana maslany was
also making jokes about this too because she's
from canada in real life and so is ryan reynolds
so because the characters they play are so meta
she was suggesting that they play on that with
a scene where they're talking in character
about being from canada but then they break
character and start talking to each other like
they're from canada and just go back and forth
the whole thing with the jansen class action i
think is a reference to kloss janssen who worked
on a ton of marvel comics and i think the class
action is just a joke about all the marvel artists
getting pissed in real life at marvel for not
actually paying them extra commissions when they
adapt the comic stories that they created for the
movies in the shows like that is a thing in real
life they set up that mcu version of tinder called
matcher for all the she-hulk dating that she does
in the series like they do it in this episode
but it'll probably continue through the rest
of the series you can guess what her password
might be but on the next page there's another
qr code that you can scan on this screen to get
another free she-hulk comic book they did the
same thing during moon night where like in most
of the episodes there's a qr code you can scan
to get free comic books she breaks the fourth
ball again to tell us her profile is perfect
but then nikki rips it apart and they set the
whole idea of her creating a dating profile for
she-hulk which is something that they actually
did in real life marvel created an actual profile
for she-hulk on the real-life tinder app you
can let me know if you actually use the app
and you saw her like you matched with she-hulk
like oh i matched with somebody wait a minute it's
she-hulk is this a real thing what no kink shaming
here because it also seems like in the mcu people
really really want the thicker version of jen
she-hulk than they want actual jennifer walters
it does seem like this is the horniest
marvel series that we've had so far
wong then shows up in her office and explains
the donnie blaise backstory and how he wants
to sue her and they make a whole bunch of
references i already explained his backstory
like how he came to come martach for a brief
period and while he was on the way out he must
have stolen the sling ring and that's how he's
causing all these problems when he gets into
the idea of inexperienced people experimenting in
interdimensional travel that's another reference
to all the mistakes and craziness that will be
caused during the events of spider-man no way
home and doctor strange multiverse of badass
like they're going to do something just as bad
multiple times very soon also the larger stuff
like untangling the material and astral planes
is a bigger deal i think and probably more of a
reference to avengers 5 kang dynasty and avengers
6 secret words with the eventual collapse of the
entire multiverse in all reality in the incursions
there are a couple references to that later in
the episode too and i think it's all references
to the incursions and stuff that we just saw in
doctor strange multiverse of madness when they
start making the jokes about the contracts that
they actually form at kamar taj like we actually
abide to a higher law the time space continuum
that's another avengers 5 kang dynasty incursions
reference in doctor strange multiverse of madness
when reed richards talks about him destabilizing
the multiverse and leading to more incursions is
kind of that energy when he mentions the book of
vashanti obviously we saw a version that during
doctor strange multiverse of madness the whole
idea with that is that it's kind of like the dark
hole temple it's not like the darkhold book they
said that there's only one book of ashanti for the
entire multiverse in the illuminati characters had
just built a backdoor to the book itself so when
scarlet witch basically burns it up there they
burn the only copy of the book the guy that tries
to hit on them is just meant to be like a rando
skeezy merry dude like he's literally listed as
married person in the credits it's just meant to
set up all the bad dates that she's about to go on
as jennifer walters not that the dates of she-hulk
are that much better unless she has that one good
date but also as she-hulk even though she gets way
more matches she still has a bunch of bad dates
they joke about the actual she-hulk name becoming
catchier and catchier her getting more comfortable
with it but i think that's meant to set up next
week's episode with the whole titania lawsuit i'll
explain what's going on with that in a second too
i couldn't find any marvel easter eggs in
the cornelius p willow's name but i already
explained how this is meant to be a magic castle
reference to the place in los angeles in real life
they have the joke about not being able to
copyright art which is obviously a lie like
as she says in the episode you can totally
copyright art wong also kind of lies a
little bit too when he says the sorcerer's supreme
doesn't engage in competition because we literally
literally last week's episode just saw him
fighting the abomination when she goes on the
first batch of bad dates as jennifer walters
the guy says he got banned from canada like i
said it's meant to be an easter egg to tatiana
maslany in real life being from actual canada
like ryan reynolds then when they have the trial
the next day donnie blaze's lawyer looks a little
bit like dan slott it's not dan slot like it's a
completely different person but it does look a lot
like him and he is a long time marvel rider when
wang asks for mercy from quan yi that's actually
an iron fist easter egg as far as i can tell
one of the first iron fist easter eggs they've
legit had in the mcu since they cancelled the iron
fist in the marvel netflix series like daredevil
obviously we have the new daredevil series coming
back maybe there'll be some iron fist easter eggs
now that a lot of those characters are coming back
like punisher will also come back eventually to
jessica jones luke cage pretty much all those
marvel netflix characters are like slowly being
folded back into the mcu in different series
and movies also you have the idea that daredevil
will cameo in a couple more episodes but the
character quan yi is actually the taoist god
of mercy which is why he asked her for extra mercy
and a lot of these scenes with madison are just
meant to set up the post credit scene where she
and wong hang out like she talks about how she's
best friends with wong now and he can't stand her
but they actually do go get froyo right after this
like okay fine we'll go get froyo but no more
spoiling the sopranos for me when wong says
donnie blaze seeks to wield the power of gods in
marvel comics it's a little bit different the way
they explain dr strange's magic and a lot of the
other big characters certain gods do grant them
powers like doctor strange and the other magic
users comic book doctor strange gets most of his
energy to power his spells by forming a contract
with the actual vishanti gods their trio of cosmic
gods like you talk about all the gods that we saw
during thor love and thunder but they changed that
a little bit for the movies i talked a lot about
this during my doctor strange two easter egg
videos because a lot of it gets into the book of
the vishanti and the way they're referencing that
his whole speech about one man causing great harm
ripples so great that they reverberate through the
entire multiverse is also a reference to you
probably guessed it doctor strange multiverse
of madness because during that movie multiple
characters tell versions of that speech to dr
strange it's also kind of a reference to what
he does during spiderman no way home wong also
references the mirror dimension saying that he
should just throw donnie blaze in there which they
pay off in the end credit scene like you see him
trapping donny plays in there as if he finally did
that after the case was over i felt like that was
actually funnier than the real post-credits scene
then she creates her dating profile as she hulk
breaks the fourth wall again two times in a row
goes on more bad dates one of them is like a super
fan of she-hulk and other superheroes because of
her fight with titania in court and then makes a
bunch of incredible hulk references talking about
bruce banner hulk you can think of that as like a
multiple level easter egg like they're referencing
the events of the incredible hulk they're
referencing the incredible whole comic books
and it sounds like within the mcu people actually
call bruce banner the incredible hulk we didn't
see thor and thor love and thunder wearing the hat
with the avengers title from the comics on it so
it does sound like a lot of the merchandise
that sold for these characters in universe
references a lot of the slogans from the comics
the fanboy starts asking her all kinds of super
deep geeky questions about her powers and whether
or not she could withstand vibranium making more
black panther references like she's gone on
a date with a comic book convention basically
she breaks the fourth wall again and then
eventually donnie blaze opens another portal
to another dimension trying to send someone back
and winds up freeing the small demons i couldn't
find any specific references to particular comic
book demons like none of the comic book demons
look like these demons so they might have created
these just for the episode while this is happening
we see wong watching the this is us episodes on
his tv setting up the post credits scene because
that's what they're watching in the post-credits
scene and she-hulk is in the middle of getting
ready to perform death by snooze new with her
date as she breaks the fourth wall again and wong
totally [__] blocks them they have their big
team up moment where they both use their powers
to throw all the demons to another portal to what
seems like a frozen dimension maybe it's niflheim
maybe it's jodenheim she breaks the fourth wall
again during their fight and i think their big
team-up moment here is meant to be sort of a
precursor for what it's going to look like when
she teams up with other avengers characters in
future movies like a bigger version of what you're
seeing happen here just in the way that marvel
characters eventually start combining their powers
you also start looking around the background
of the magic venue there's a thurston poster
that might be a reference to the thurston comedy
club that one of pat and oswald's characters on
agents of shield worked at they also did versions
of ghostwriter during that series and they're
referencing ghostwriter during this episode so
you can think of it sort of like a connection
with all those different things when we go back
to her date he's reading a book by roxanne gay
she's also written some of the more recent black
panther comics too like she's another marvel comic
book creator and we get our death by snooze
new moment everyone pour one out for that dude
taking one for the team he's gonna enjoy every
minute of that computer sentences then to death
by snooze new yeah yeah it would have been a
little bit funnier if he had waddled out the
next morning but like they have that funny moment
where she comes back as jennifer walters making
breakfast and he doesn't want to have anything to
do with her like oh wait a minute you're regular
you know what i'm going to take off right now
goodbye i think just setting up the idea that
she's going to want to spend more and more time
as she-hulk just because it seems like everybody
for many different reasons in aspects of her life
like she-hulk more than they like regular jennifer
walters and titania sues her claiming that
her company owns the sheet hulk name trademark
titania is a she-hulk comic book character like
she's been a she-hulk villain for a long time
so this is just setting up them going
to court with each other in episode 5.
what probably happened is she's doing this to get
back at jennifer walters using the courts to do it
titania probably just trademarked the name before
jennifer walters thought to do it and people
do this in real life all the time to try and work
some sort of settlement out with them like you
got to pay me a lot of money now it's just a way
to extort money out of people and she breaks the
fourth wall again talking about how the ending
is a downer but the actual post credit scene is
going to be way more fun she did this in last
week's episode too like we all realize you're
watching for the really cool cameo that's going
to happen in this episode but there's actually
a lot of other stuff going on too and it's meant
to be my series like she's joking about how people
aren't remembering that it's actually her series
during the end credits with all the courtroom art
the new scenes they added are madison signing her
contract selling her soul away apparently in this
hell dimension with the goat demon who is wearing
the jake name tag but the whole idea like i said
is that this is sort of like a courtroom artist's
depiction of what madison told him and it's
madison kind of misremembering things a little bit
this is she-hulk just cleaning off the demon gunk
before she goes back for death by snooze stew and
then donnie blaze stuck in the mirror dimension
paying off wong's threat probably my favorite
scene from like all the new post credit scenes
i wonder how long wong trapped him in there
and in the actual post-credits scene wang
and madison just hang out together watching the
this is us episode talking about all the drinks
that they've tried and her getting excited about
trying goat's milk that they have left over from
the last big wedding they performed at camartage
next week's episode will be a big titanium episode
we'll see which other big cameos and references
that they make and other abomination stuff that
might be going on if you spotted any other easter
eggs or references in the episode that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments my full episode 5 video will post
next week just like normal my house the dragon
episode 4 video will post this weekend there's
a bunch of series that i'm doing episode videos
for right now and we have all the marvel disney
plus day trailers that'll be coming this weekend
so whatever it is they drop big announcements
trailers i'll do videos for all that stuff so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
probably gonna get a bunch of fantastic four news
as well too everyone click here for my house of
the dragon episode 4 trailer video and click here
for my full house of the dragon episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!